cher evans hansson aujourd'hui ça va
être une super journée et voici pourquoi
[Musique]
quitté i des lettres à toi même comme tu
as dit le docteur german j'essaie de le
faire
revivre
ball et où ces personnes assignées ton
plâtre
pour faire croire qu'on a des amis je
suis désolé pour mon frère jumeau fauga
le nom
ouais je voudrais que tout soit
différent je voudrais trouver ma place
je voudrais que ce que je dis quant à
vous offrir
que
oui c'est à moi je vais la récupérer à
temps attendant la mort
et non un nouveau pied
connor a pris ma lettre c'était un
exercice collectif il est loin le temps
comme ce que j'aime tout la mère et le
beau-père de connors de tout voir onu ni
de frais
voulais te donner sa moelle de broc et
le shérif en scène il a écrit m c'était
un hymne o'connor s'est suicidé
je suis désolé c'est pas lui qui a écrit
ça non s'il te plaît qu'est ce que c'est
elle obéit fin on pensait pas que connor
avait des amis
[Musique]
actu va vraiment dire à des parents que
tout ce qui leur reste de leur fils
écrite à toi même alors qu'au nord et
toi t'es nous quelque chose d'accord
j'ai commencé à parler sans t'arrêter il
voulait pas que je m'arrête a organisé
une commémoration si tu veux participer
couleurs m'a montré que je n'étais pas
seule
personne des salles où sort un table en
effet ray moi j'aurais
reese
je dis pas que tu parles moi non plus
on est plat ressentir ça ok
et
là
[Musique]
les gens partagent la vidéo elle est
partout
je ne sais pas comment c'est arrivé
grâce à toi
si magique parce que tu as apporté à ma
famille et à moi
est ce que vous étiez le nom eni
[Musique]
si jamais voulu qu'on en arrive là je
voulais aider
cité me connaissez vraiment si tu servi
à quel point je suis brisé
j'étais connaît déjà
là et je t'aime
il faut que je redis c'est
e